So, the first requirement clearly refers to some specific functionality of
the Bowling Alley system, because it talks about what the system has
to do from a functional standpoint. So, it's definitely not a non-functional
requirement. On the other hand, the fact that the Word Count system
should be able to process large files, is telling us something not
about the functionality of the system, but rather about its qualities. The
fact that it has to be scalable, that it has to be
efficient and so we can consider this to be a non-functional requirement.
Similarly, the fact that the Login program for a
website should be secure is definitely telling us something
about the quality of the system that has little
to do with its functionality. And so this is
also a non-functional requirement. Finally, the fact that the
Vending Machine program should take coins as an input
from the user is telling us something about the
functionality of the program and therefore, is a functional requirement.